okay we have a reddit discussion forum a
well moderated and well attended reddit
discussion forum with nearly 5,000 of
our viewers and listeners at david
pakman.com slash read it I was on the
discussion forum this morning checking
out some of the latest discussions and I
wanted to run a couple of these by you
so that you could maybe get interested
in participating starting with of course
the war on terrorism which is sort of
always an issue I mean it's been an
issue now for at least 16 years the
concept of the global war on terrorism
and we have a post that argues the war
on terrorism will never end and that the
ISIS mentality will never be defeated
because it is two omnipresent check out
that discussion I would love to hear
your thoughts on it also on our reddit
discussion forum trump's approval rating
a user who suggests that the reason why
people are not jumping ship in terms of
saying I no longer support the president
is pride they don't want to admit to
themselves that they supported Donald
Trump and I don't exactly get what that
means because if it's pride then it's
not about cognitive dissonance it could
be one or the other I don't know how it
could be both but it's an interesting
conversation nonetheless about what if
anything will it take for these 32 to 38
percent of the country who's still of
the countries voters that still support
Trump what if anything will it take for
them to abandon ship also on the reddit
discussion forum the best part of any
White House press briefing is hearing
David laughing and snickering in the
background when Sarah Huckabee Sanders
tries to explain herself not everybody
likes that every time that we play a
clip and I just can't resist laughing
because it's so absurd and insane some
people say that it adds to the
experience for them and others say David
could you please shut up I'm just trying
to hear the clip I don't want to hear
you laughing just try to keep quiet or
mute your microphone so that is actually
more controversial than you might
imagine and lastly from our reddit
discussion forum the truth of burger
eating is David a genius I revealed the
other day or I guess restated I've
discussed this before on the bonus show
that I sort of eat burgers upside down I
guess you would say and I can do a real
quick demonstration if you cut back to
me where if you imagine these two blue
pieces of paper
as the bun and imagine the white as the
burger itself and I've got a sandwich
and these are the sesame seeds on top
many people would sort of pick it up and
bring it directly to their mouth
maintaining the sesame seed bun on top
right I do something else which is I
flip it and it ends up with the bun on
the top bun on the bottom and this has
created a lot of controversy some people
furious with me but I maintain that it's
a good idea because your taste buds are
on your tongue
typically the condiments go towards the
top of the burger so if you flip it you
actually are putting the condiments in
touch with your tongue and actually
tasting the full flavor profile of the
burger so anyway a lot of controversy
about that but certainly I have my
supporters when it comes to burger
eating and yeah you can weigh in at
david pakman.com slash reddit